our glow up expert is back Pearl Skin
studio the sponsors of this segment are
here to talk about body wrapping Katya
I'm so excited to talk about this this
is all the rage right now you know out
there with lymphatic massages body
wrapping so let's get to it what is body
wrapping for those who don't know
um so I'm gonna talk about meliss detox
body wrap it has a story beautiful story
to it so it was developed by a
biochemist okay at UCLA Medical Center
so it was developed to increase
to encourage lymphatic flow for patients
who has neuropathy and diabetes okay and
then the amazing Discovery came during
those studies that because of that
increased lymphatic flow it provides
internal cleansing that leads to
Permanent Inch loss this is amazing it's
permanent into US permanent enchilots I
know you guys are really listening now
okay so what's the process like to get
this so when the patient comes we
usually exfoliate the body on heated bed
then we're seeing the process right now
yeah you take a shower then we apply
special magical cream with niacin and
cinnamon to increase blood circulation
we wrap you specific way to provide
lymphatic drainage and then we tuck you
in comfortably in the bed and
it's great for to quiet your mind
because it feels so good most of the
patients fall asleep right it sounds
relaxing yes and you can add facial to
it
we can step out of the room for you to
sleep okay it's your choice I love that
facials chemical peels and a body wrap
yeah yeah that's the perfect that's a
perfect afternoon or evening now when do
you usually see results from the body
wrap so it's immediate result but we
love you have the best result you should
get four to six treatments once a week
okay if you're getting ready for special
event and you want to fit into specific
clothing and have your legs firm and
tied arms tight
this is amazing Contours your body
detoxifies provide lymphatic drainage
and feels amazing for your mind that is
incredible now lastly here you have a
special offer for September so tell
everybody what you're doing yeah when
you book guys your detox Melissa detox
body wrap you get complimentary
bioglycolic cleanser by Gian Marini full
size that you can use for your face and
your body and it is exfoliating cleanser
thank you so much Katya that sounds
incredible thank you to Pearl Skin
studio for sponsoring this segment now
if you're ready for your glow up call
702-525-5504 or
pearlskinstudio.com book that detox
Contour body wrap in September and just
mentioned you were on Las Vegas now
where you saw them on Las Vegas now and
receive a free full-size jamarini
bioglycolic cleanser that's a 50 value
for free yeah yes we'll take it thank
you so much Katya thank you